to me
[music]
Marguerite, a great wake up
I've prepared a little party for my brother I hope you like it
Haven't you heard from the girl
I'm his friend Did my
brother have another horse Like a
hunt
I heard about my brother from him. He said that he was
a woman like a goddess
.
I think,
please, the
answer is
you, ah,
let everyone die and destroy them, ah, the one
who makes everything this way, the
one who seems to celebrate it,
I see
.
No
one should hold such barley against other companies, but because of the
past, it's an infallible guillotine In other
words, what kind of heart did you buy?
I went
to conquer and enjoy the way I love
[music]
e I don't like it.
]